[Music]
hello Yuri Capelli journey Bobby Bobby
Riggs listen I had a great idea male
chauvinist pig versus hairy light
feminist no offense you're still a
feminist right I'm a tennis player who
happens to be a woman oh by the way I
shaved my legs we are privileged tennis
fans to have the great Billie Jean King
word is you are a renegade women should
be paid and respected equally I admire
what you guys are doing you're offering
the men's better eight times what you're
offering the women's blender the men are
simply more exciting to watch it's just
biology I am NOT saying that women don't
belong on the course who would pick up
the balls otherwise oh my god you know
what I'm doing I'm cooking I'm cooking
isn't a single thing I don't hate it by
Bobby Riggs
I'm in thousand dogs that any woman who
can be Bobby Riggs you see out there and
does she have the nerve
call Bobby Tom it's on so early team
what do you want whatever I feel I can't
act on it there's too much at stake
business sports you name it the very top
it's a man's world v can be Bobby Riggs
he's never gonna let it go we are alive
in three I'm gonna be the best so that
way I can really one change things when
we dare to one a little bit more just a
little bit of what you got that's what
you can't see
ladies and gentlemen I'm gonna put the
shell back and shoulders he can talk all
you like dinosaurs can't play tennis
forty million people are watching any
last words
I'm done talking affect the battle
you've all been waiting to see the
battle of the sexes
[Music]